- Keep it movin' now.
Keep it movin', people.
♪♪♪
- Whatchu need, sir?
- How do you get to the stadium from here?
- The stadium...
♪♪♪
I don't know, sir. I really—
I don't even work here.
♪♪♪
- Let's do it.
- They have no idea what
they're about to get. The city of
Atlanta, the coolest crossing guard
in the history of the world.
- They have ever seen.
♪♪♪
- Hey, sweetie, how you doin' today?
You good?
Patriots? What?!
♪♪♪
Keep the walkway clear.
That's how you know ain't no real
Rams fans. Only got Eric Dickerson jerseys!
- [Laughing]
♪♪♪
- They have no idea.
They don't understand who just— a security
guard just touched his head and he's like
"Why are you touching me?"
Cuz he's Odell.
- Whatchu need, sir?
- How do you get to the stadium from here?
♪♪♪
Ohh! Giants, baby!
- Yeah!
- Yes indeed. Hey, look.
Don't tell nobody I'm out here workin'.
- [Laughing]
♪♪♪
- Oh, you from New Orleans, huh?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I already knew that. Cuz I'm with it.
- Oh, yeah?
- Ohh! What's up, Odell?!
Odell, baby!
- You good?
- Uh-oh, here it comes.
They've been spotted.
♪♪♪
- [Cheering]
- Go! Go!
♪♪♪